strength we gain strength and courage
and confidence by each experience in
which we really stop to look fear in the
face we must do that which we think we
cannot Eleanor Roosevelt how do you do
it where do you find the strength to do
all these big things that's the question
I came in from Twitter and the answer is
simple if you want to have strength and
feel more energy stop working on
projects that bring you down that suck
your energy that drain your life force
if you're forcing yourself to do
something stop get rid of it this is not
your path you won't build anything great
by repeatedly doing things that you hate
instead focus on what gives you energy
things you look forward to projects you
actually enjoy writing the business is
brutally hard you might as well be doing
something you actually like here's my
process like most entrepreneurs I like
starting projects I like the new I love
the challenge it's fun and then I get
bored of it I build things up myself
typically investing no money and only my
time you don't need money to do
something amazing just heart
I see how far along it is by the time I
get bored and then I decide to kill the
project or hand it off to someone to run
with I do this over and over and over
again it's a process and it works
sometimes they get bored after an hour
and stop sometimes it lasts for weeks or
months some projects I haven't gotten
tired of yet at all as soon as I get
tired of something my productivity and
the quality of my output drops my
happiness level energy and strength drop
off to better to move on to something
else and either i've taken it far enough
along that someone else can take over
for me and it will help my business or
it's too experimental and it's not worth
continuing to invest in but move on when
you don't bring passion anymore to your
business everybody suffers your
customers won't be as responsive your
team won't be as productive you're
failing will notice that you're not
happy it's too important to your own
life and the people around you that you
stop doing things you hate and focus on
projects that you love it's okay to
change I'm not doing the same thing as I
was a decade ago when I started this
business everybody changes wrigley
started off as a soap company BMW
started off as an airplane manufacturer
Lamborghini started off selling tractors
you will change to you have to change so
the next time you find yourself doing
something for too long and finding that
your energy and strength are gone think
about what excites you and go do that
amazing things will come out of it
believe
you